Washington Journal continues and joining
us from New York City this morning
president and CEO of the polling company
Republican pollster Kellyanne Conway -
to look at the President's speech the
aftermath of both the Democratic and
Republican convention Kelly and Conway
thank you for being with us this morning
good morning what did you think of the
President's speech and what do you think
the key message that he was he was
trying to deliver I was really surprised
by the President's speech it wasn't his
finest moment I think last night was the
best evidence I've seen so far that
Barack Obama 2012 is really just sort of
a a smaller hollow less joyful version
of Barack Obama 2008 it seemed to me
that his speech was way under the more
compared to his own wife's speech which
was very well received and very well
delivered and of course former President
Bill Clinton's speech having set the
table for President Obama the night
before and why do I say that well it's
he seemed to play the victim and
presidents want the Americans want their
presidents to be optimistic and true
leaders and to have that feeling that
they're in charge that they're the
captain of the ship and even if the ship
is listing a little bit that they can
right that ship and they can they'll
stay at the helm and he talked he talked
about growing the government I thought
that was really remarkable for me I mean
even if he wants to grow the government
I would have thought in his big
primetime speech and appealing to these
voters and trying to get to that 50
percent mark again against Romney he
would have a little bit more optimistic
vision for creating jobs and solving
this this conundrum of everyday
affordability which is what people are
really complaining about people are
nervous about the rising cost of food
and fuel they're not trying to afford
the luxuries or trying to get through
the day and I carry ously bill last
night was the first time ever realized
I think Chicago I think the Obama
campaign is in part running a
challengers campaign instead of him
getting up there and talking as a
confident incumbent give me four more
years so we can continue to do what
we're doing he basically is is saying
this hasn't gone right and they stood in
my way we need four more years to to
continue to do what we're doing because
it has
been enough yet and he himself this past
week the president gave himself a grade
of quote incomplete and you you heard
that in the speech last night so I was
surprised I thought it was a real missed
opportunity for someone who is a skilled
orator coming off of a convention where
you had some some real signature
speeches including ironically by his own
wife and his predecessor and Bill
Clinton who are 20 points more popular
than President Obama is we have our
phone lines open the viewers can see 202
737 triple 0 one for Democrats
Republicans that's 202 737 triple zero
to independence 202 6 to 8 0 to 0-5 and
we'll also check Twitter for your your
tweets this morning Kellyanne Conway as
the campaign really begins today now
that the nominees are official and both
of them head out on the road today what
are over the next day 8 weeks or so what
are the key polls that you're looking at
or that viewers should keep an eye on
that may give us a real indication of
how this race is heading it's a great
question let me say what we should not
look at first which are the horse race
numbers we all obsess over who's up and
who's down and the fact is that neither
a Governor Romney nor President Obama
have been able to crack 50% and stay
there against the other so that's
actually less relevant than all of the
underlying numbers that we should be
looking at so there are probably seven
or eight swing states where most of us
will be putting our attention and I
think where most of the research will be
done in these last these last wee
remaining weeks and those states are no
surprise to anyone what I see happening
recently bill is that the presidential
race in these seven or eight swing
states is pretty much tied but that
you've got Senate candidates and in a
couple of cases gubernatorial candidates
that are starting to pull away and leave
their opponent whether they're
Republican or Democrat so it's
fascinating to me that voters out there
are splitting their tickets already
saying I'm going to reelect incumbent X
or I'm going to go for this type of
vision at the Senate or Governor level
and yet I still have the two
presidential candidates at parity and I
think the Susan page article that you
referenced earlier in USA Today really
tells the tale of what we'll be looking
at which are the so-called swing voters
people who are truly undecided they're
not understand
not undecided about whether they will
participate in the election they've
already made that decision they'll be
there they're undecided as to whom to
support why many of them are female they
tend to be predominantly female who tend
to be late in the game deciders but for
many of these suburban women who tend to
be married and have school-aged children
many of them supported President Obama
in 2008 but then they turned around in
support of Republicans at the
Congressional level in 2010 when the
issues on the table were very fiscal in
nature so these for these women debt is
a four-letter word they were concerned
about the stimulus the bailouts the
price tag of Obamacare which curiously
President Obama didn't even mention last
night supposed to be a signature
domestic piece of legislation and he
didn't touch it last night so that's
very telling these women are very
important they'll decide this election
frankly in seven or eight states well
here's here's here's one of those
snapshot polls that you mentioned this
is ABC News the ABC news/washington post
poll about where women register where
women registered voters are as of the
end of August they had it at 49% for
President Obama 43 percent supporting
Governor Romney your own organization
the polling company just came out with a
broader poll on women and issues in the
2012 campaign what's the biggest
takeaway that our viewers should know
about that poll the biggest takeaway
from that poll is that women are a
little conflicted between how they feel
and what they know when it comes to this
president they feel that he's likable
that he tries hard that they were happy
to help make history with him four years
ago they very much believed in hope and
change an optimistic vision but what
they that's how they feel what they know
is that he has not been able to deliver
on his own promises to jumpstart the
economy to create jobs women have lost
860,000 jobs under obama the extreme
poverty rate for women is the highest
ever recorded in this country housing
values are down the cost of food and
fuel is up so women are conflicted
between sort of their heart and their
head and I have to say Bill it seems
that even though biology and chemistry
certainly are important to female voters
this year math is the most important
subject to them
and they are able to do the math or able
to understand the facts and figures and
of course the question are you better
off than you were four years ago is an
important one and women all across this
country will be asking it but they're
also asking themselves a question that I
don't believe that the president
answered last night in his speech that
question is four more years of what make
the case for why I should have you on my
team why I should have you as the
captain that ship for four more years
what will be different how will my life
be different and I think that the clues
to 2012 particularly among female voters
lie in a combination of how they behave
in 2008 when 56% of them voted for
President Obama and how they behaved in
2010 when for the first time ever
women favored Republicans over Democrats
at the Congressional level and let me
just close by telling you what they
don't really care that much about women
certainly it's part of their weekly
conversation to discuss abortion or
contraception or gay marriage but
there's no indication it's part of the
voter motivation there's a difference
weekly conversation voter motivation in
nobody's polls in absolutely nobody's
polls is abortion contraception gay
marriage in the top three to five issues
for men or women and I'm just I'm just
struck really struck actually confounded
that the Democrats thought the way to
message to women was to give primetime
speaking slots to the president of
Planned Parenthood and to a law student
who gained national notoriety by talked
by asking the government to cover the
expense of her contraception the
Republicans frankly put up ethnic
governors like nikki Haley the first
Indian American female governor in this
country from South Carolina susana
Martinez the first Latina governor in
the history of this country to
Republicans to chief executives talking
about what they're doing in their very
different states South Carolina and New
Mexico to help grow the economy so women
you know women care about these issues
but there's no indication that it
motivates their votes the economy will
Kellyanne Conway Republican pollster
plenty of Capitol Hill in Washington
experience with jack kemp Dan Quayle and
others and now president and CEO of the
polling company and their new poll out
for lifetime television the political
poll we're talking about issues in the
2012 presidential campaign coming out of
the the conventions we go first to st.
Louis Missouri Carroll is on our
Democrats line go ahead yeah this is
exactly why you can't trust the polls
the people who do them are so biased
it's amazing and then they talk religion
well how about nuns on the bus
supporting Obama how about a lot of
people really I think the majority like
the health care plan I know I do my
granddaughters what's on it till she was
26 and she has a pre-existing condition
and the last thing is she talked about
what do women talk about weekly I'm
absolutely positive they do not talk
weekly about millionaires meeting tax
break
Kellyanne Conway any reaction I'm not
sure there's a question in there but i
SPECT her opinion certainly I would just
ask her or I'm actually asking out loud
why the President himself did not talk
about the affordable care act that she
is bragging about on his behalf I mean
it's it's pretty remarkable to me that
that as soon as the Supreme Court came
out and upheld the legality of the
affordable care act a few months ago
based on Congress's taxing power that
the President did not mention it in his
radio address that very weekend didn't
mention it the next weekend and then
didn't talk about it at any length last
night in his primetime speech um he
spent more time the President did last
night talking about how much he doesn't
like negative ads his quote was if
you're sick of hearing me approve this
message believe me so am I
how does he have standing to say that
when his campaign is spending millions
of dollars that are also coming from the
millionaire's she's talking about in
negative advertising I mean this is what
I'm this is what I'm suggesting that
he's running a challengers campaign
instead of incumbents campaign because
that's what a challenge usually says I'm
going to go up against the system
this man is part of the system he's
complicit in the system and her comment
about nuns on the bus for Obama I
respect the right of everybody to make
their own choices there are plenty of
people who believe in the social justice
agenda
and the war on poverty but I would ask
those nuns to please explain to me as
somebody who was schooled by nuns her
entire life and a proud and devout
Catholic how can you how can you square
President Obama's record with the
extreme poverty rate being the highest
ever recorded I mean when when is he
actually going to take responsibility
for that people are suffering that is
not a political point that is an
economic fact and it's a sad one to
Kentucky Huntsville no excuse me
Madisonville Kentucky this is ROI on our
Republican life
hey good morning sir Warren now I just
got a couple plane stays more uh brocco
bomber and then he likes Carville White
Sox and I do too but my point is is
which one's gonna be better Mitt Romney
or a rock Obama you know they keep
saying the same thing both of them all
right all weren't saying something
different the other one saying something
different but which point is going to
come down to the boat you know which
one's going to be more majority and what
we're going to do for this conjurer
that's my question today what what one
president is going to turn this country
around for the jobs coal mines steel
mill all rigs and every time we gotta
have all in this country
we gotta have cold we gotta burn trash
that burn coal what you know and the
tornadoes and stuff it just comes you
know comes and goes Royall let Kellyanne
respond I'm so glad to get a question on
energy because I think energy is a real
sleeper issue to this electorate and in
breaking the back of this 4848 split
really between Romney and Obama energy
it will never be a top issue in the
polls but it brings together the things
that people say are most important to
them job creation domestic dependence
less dependence on foreign leaders and
their resources and certainly a more
vibrant economy we just did a whole
bunch of research in swing states in
Nationwide for a new National Energy
Foundation
I was really struck by voters telling us
the difference between what's nice to
have and what they need to have nice to
have with the alternative fuels later on
like solar and wind maybe even nuclear
but need to have now are American jobs a
more vibrant economy less dependence
abroad and frankly something that's made
in the USA everybody complains nothing's
made here anymore and that's a
legitimate complaint we have such
incredible abundant resources off of our
shores and right under our feet that's
made in the USA resources including oil
gas coal and this gentleman and probably
realizes that for many of these
blue-collar so-called Reagan Democrats
and white working-class voters for whom
the jobs are not coming back in
construction and manufacturing that have
been lost energy really is that arena
with this hydraulic fracturing and
different types of technologies where a
lot of these jobs are ready-made
for men and women who are looking for a
long term financial security and I think
energy is an incredibly important issue
I know Governor Romney came out with an
energy plan last week during his
convention I know that President Obama
has talked about energy President Obama
of course you know he allowed Solyndra
to get hundreds of millions of dollars
in government money and they failed
that's our money and that was the big
gamble for solar meanwhile people you
know right now we rely on oil and gas
and I'll tell you gas prices are the
floor not the ceiling when it comes to
this energy debate I'm very I'm very
struck and very impressed by the average
Americans conversin see on on energy
issues right now they get it and they're
listening to their politicians to get it
doctor calls Los Angeles California
Chuck's on our independence line good
morning good morning how you guys doing
doing fine great it's great to have a
couple of minutes to express my opinion
here let's start out with the health
care bill to me if you take out of an
equation the insurance companies they
don't bring anything to the table except
their profits if I'm dealing with my
hell
I want to deal with my doctor my
acupuncturist my other type of holistic
type doctors because they're the ones
that are going to heat I think we lost a
chop there Kellyanne will move on while
I got his point now and it's an
important one I think we've heard from
voters for three years now since the
Affordable Care Act was first introduced
bill and it's very simple voters don't
want them voters see as patient doctor
and then right in between the government
and they don't want that that's what
scares them there's no question that we
need health care reform in this country
there's no question that there are
people who need access to health care
that's it that's that's a noble goal
which we all share but that the trillion
plus dollar expensive of the Affordable
Care Act and frankly the fear that many
people had particularly women who
control two out of every three
healthcare dollars spent in this country
they were very concerned about a lack of
quality a loss of consistency I know
where the pediatrician is where to park
I know I can help grandma navigate
Medicare Part D and osteoporosis
medication that that lack of consistency
uncertainty for them was very scary and
really if the bailouts and the stimulus
and the spending at the beginning of the
Obama administration were the tip of the
iceberg health care was really the
tipping point if you go back and look at
what happened in 2010 and some of the
reservations these swing female voters
currently have about this president and
reelecting him it really goes back to
his health care plan I think his
pollsters must know that which is why he
didn't even mention it last night well
your your organization the polling
company just did this political poll for
lifetime television did you ask
specifically yes or no are women happy
with the the health plan we did we
actually asked a question about what
they if they think what they think of
President Obama switching his position
on gay marriage and will it cost him
votes or win him votes or will it not
matter and then we asked a question
about health care we actually asked what
women thought about the Supreme Court
decision on health care 51% said they
supported it I actually thought not that
number would be 20 points higher or so
because women are very respectful of
Authority and they know the Supreme
Court is the last word on such things
unless the Congress comes back and
as legislation and so I really thought
just in deference to the courts
authority alone more women across this
country would say look people who didn't
like it litigated it they tried they
went all the way up to the Supremes
they've upheld it including the
conservative chief - chief justice let's
just implement it and see where it goes
but there's some real hesitation there
and it's not a partisan split you know
independent women are very skeptical of
government that's why they're
independent and they look at the heart
they look at the health care plan not
according to the heartstrings issue of
the woman who is deny the mammogram
three times the little boy who couldn't
get the transplant in time horrible
stories for which we should all
concentrate on a solution they look at
it for its price tag and its expansive
expensive intrusive nature and so you
see that in the lifetime poll which I'm
glad you're mentioning things you can
find on our website or lifetime's
website I was really a nice deep dive
among America's women on policy issues
here's Michelle she's on our Democrats
line in Uniontown Pennsylvania go ahead
yes good morning thanks for taking my
call I just wanted to say that your
guest she's got it all wrong I don't
know what convention suit what speech
she was watching last night but the
president I think he laid out very well
what he has accomplished and what he
plans on doing and I know the American
people and I could tell by the people
that were there last May they all
understand and everybody you know I
don't understand where you're getting
all this information what you're putting
out here but I believe the president you
know he came into the office to a mess
and I think he desires for more years to
get us going and I believe he will and I
don't understand where you're getting
how you can go in there and say the
things that you're saying and that's all
I had to say thank you very much for
taking my call Thank You Michelle Kelly
uncomely any thoughts yes Michelle I
appreciate that I think you've echoed
with the chief message from the
Democrats back to when it Bill's
original questions is going to be the
next couple weeks which is four more
years is not enough we need four more
years because it just simply isn't
enough the clocks about to run out and
Bill Clinton tried to make that case
from the night before but if you go and
read a bunch of different newspapers
today a very very respected journalist
you will see very lukewarm reaction to
the president's talk last night this
began with having to move the entire
speech from a 70,000 plus venue outside
for which they couldn't sell enough
tickets
free tickets to the 17,000 seat venue
where he was going to be comfortable and
at home
I'm sure the delegates the Democratic
convention thought it was a great speech
the people in the arena but it does it
certainly wasn't a 2008 Obama speech and
I would just point your attention to a
Glenn Kessler from the Washington Post
he's the fact checker there he's really
pulling apart the president's claim on
the four billion dollar debt ridden debt
reduction package this morning that's
simply what the president said just does
not make economic sense it won't work
and I can understand as a partisan why
you saw this as a very uplifting evening
I actually was crediting the President
as a gifted orator who was able to you
know sort of very big heights four years
ago and I just didn't see that last
night so it's that simple we are getting
your reaction to last night's speech and
hearing from Kellyanne Conway Republican
pollster and headline here in Chicago
Chicago's Tribune the hometown newspaper
for the Obamas we are moving forward no
quick fix to nation's challenges Winter
Haven Florida is next up on a Republican
line Cassandra go ahead yes I voted for
the bushes back in the day and I think
the reason Obama didn't include that and
his speech was basically because if I
beat the dead dog we talked about it
enough we need to move on but basically
the problem stands with everybody
talking about Obamacare it's not
Obamacare he didn't do that
Kellyanne Conway on Cassandra's point
there about the bushes there was some
some thinking that the the president and
some of his speeches leading up to the
convention had mentioned the previous
administration
there wasn't much talk of the George W
Bush administration last night well not
from the president but he had some of
his surrogates doing the dirty work I
actually the this whole blaming the bush
thing if you look at polls it really has
run its course i mean george w bush
doesn't put himself out there was a
public figure much anymore he went on
this book tour a few years ago but other
than that you haven't seen him he
certainly didn't go to the convention in
tampa it's not like he's on you know
playing a pundit to give some post
speech commentary after the deans
you mention and that's to be respected
he said years ago he's not going to get
in the way of his successor and that's
that's great but I noticed that the
Democrats went for broke in terms of
criticizing Mitt Romney and instead of
again really being able to talk in a
very sustained very confident way about
all the great that's been done in the
first four years of the Obama
administration if you go back and just
add it all up from these past three
nights bill you'll see that there's much
more about Mitt Romney and how terribly
is in offshore accounts and tax breaks
for the rich and the whole kitchen sink
and the Republicans in Congress then
there really was you know XY and Z about
what the president's done and why you
should continue forward so I think this
woman is on to something in that people
get tired of you looking back you know
they expect their presidents to be
forward-looking and with the exception
of 1972 for the last 50 years Americans
have voted for the presidential
candidate who they saw as more
optimistic more visionary more
forward-looking frankly just more
pleasant and so that's Kennedy over
Nixon that's that's Carter over Ford and
then it's Reagan over Carter and Mondale
it's Bill Clinton over George Herbert
Walker Bush and then Bob Dole it's
George W Bush over Gore and carry you
it's Barack Obama over Hillary and and
John McCain and so I think that's a big
message to both Governor Romney and
President Obama moving forward I don't
think either of them can claim the
mantle right now on September 7th of
being the more optimistic candidate for
president and I would definitely give
them that advice in the next couple you
just said about the looking for a
candidate who's more pleasant I think I
think you said you earlier had mentioned
that you thought the president last
night was less joyful so you see the
issue of a candidate's personality being
a factor among among voters this year it
is but let's not confuse that with
likability were sort of the the their
personal story I mean I think it's great
that their respective wives of the two
nominees got up there and gave really
powerful speeches about their husbands
and about their visions and
and just who they are off of the
campaign trail I think that's great
but it makes for great TV all these
personal actives make for great TV but
this year with people suffering
economically as they are and feeling
very vulnerable and also very frustrated
about future prospects and a lack of
recovery I think that math is more
important than chemistry and so it makes
for great TV but up but as we continue
in the next two months bill it seems
that you know what not just what have
you done in the last four years but what
can you do in the next four will be the
important question and I think
likeability is very overrated of course
we want to like our leaders but people
will like you if they feel that you can
provide them with economic prosperity
and if you can provide them with some
type of financial security and everyday
affordability that makes you pretty
likeable let's go to our independence
line Gary is in Detroit morning Gary a
good morning thank you for c-span I
spent most of my young adult life as a
Republican I fail from this line about
how they are little creators of business
I no longer believe that I believe that
it without you can create a business any
time you want to but if you don't have
the public there to support that because
you're not going to have a business and
all my life I worked very hard I paid
all my taxes did everything I should do
within the one time when I moved out
into a wild of a ranch and tried to make
it on my own I did not have insurance
and wouldn't you know it that's when I
came down was not only a heart problem
but also colon cancer and for the first
time in my life had nothing to fall back
on what on the dole so to speak went on
food stamps the lowest point in my life
had it not been for getting help from
the local government the state
government and the federal government
and eventually getting on to Medicare I
would never have survived and as far as
the I'm no longer Republican and will
never support a Republican again
and as far as the Democrats taking
responsibility for this and why you're
asking while they don't take
responsibility they'll never take
responsibility for something that the
Republicans are drove us into this was a
ditch that the Republicans drove us into
Gary we'll hear from Kellyanne conway
thank you thank you Gary and let me just
begin by saying I'm glad that your
health has turned the corner I'm glad
you're talking to us and sharing your
story and thank you for doing that I'm
on the issue of Medicare it's it's
really Barack Obama's the first
Democratic president in history to
actually have cut Medicare
the fact is 716 billion dollars in cuts
to Medicare through acute care through
the Affordable Care Act and it's it's
Paul Ryan chiefly but the romney-ryan
ticket that has has a solution has a
plan on the table you can access it
right now as we speak as to how to save
Medicare for the future we as a nation
have made a promise to seniors and to
what I call junior seniors who are
coming up through the pipeline and
expecting Medicare and Social Security
for that matter that we must honor we
must do that as Americans that is the
floor not the ceiling we must honor that
but what do we do for your my children
or your grandchildren how do we know
they're going to have access to what you
needed when you needed it most
and so in projecting forward 20 30 50
years even how do we know that the
promises we can keep to seniors and
junior seniors now will be there and so
I'm just you know every Republican
running for reelection in Congress all
to stand up and say for 30 times I was
asked to cut Medicare by 716 billion
dollars and 30 times I said no I voted
no and that's a big that's a very big
problem in Obamacare and the Affordable
Care Act however you want to call it and
I think it's again it's part of why his
folks don't need hardly even mention it
Medicare is a big problem and now that
Ryan's on the romney-ryan ticket that
issue at least is on the table let's
have an honest and intelligent debate
all of us about how to honor those
promises to people like you who are
currently in the system and then sustain
it for future generations little under
10 minutes with Kellyanne Conway on
issues in the twin
twelve campaign and back to the role of
women in the campaign a report from
Charlotte but in the Baltimore Sun in
the Tribune newspaper this morning in a
town called Charlotte it's a woman's
world as the headline and they they
quote actually I guess we had on
yesterday who was the Emily Phyllis
president Stephanie shriyak who said
that keep in mind in 2008 ten more ten
million more women than men voted in
this country I think it's great to see
both conventions gearing more towards
women
former Republican strategist Nicole
Wallace they right speaking from New
York said that what's interesting to me
is that each side is talking to
different groups of women and Romney's
speech was aimed at women of her
generation Sandra Fluke was trying to
evoke a new generation of reproductive
freedom warriors your thoughts on that
there's no question that's true and of
course Sandra Fluke got a primetime
speaking slot at the Democratic National
Convention if people don't know who that
is I mean this is the Georgetown Law
student who is claim to fame is she
couldn't afford our contraception even
though I believe it's nine dollars at
Target but it's but but so it just shows
you the difference between the two
parties if you do want if you believe
that the future short term and long term
is mostly about abortion contraception
and you thought it was a great idea to
give a prime-time speaking slot to a law
student who was complaining about the
price of contraception and to the
president of Planned Parenthood and you
want to vote for a party whose own party
platform go and read it folks don't
blame the Republican pollster his own
party platform makes no exceptions to
abortion on demand anyone anytime
anywhere
sex selective abortions you want to
choose the section terrific late term
great I mean versus versus the
Republican Party trying to reach out to
I think not just a women of Ann Romney's
generation but also to working moms too
and the Democrats are reaching out to
unmarried women I think everybody should
be reaching out to all women and they
ought to understand just by looking at
everybody's polls bills bill that women
are most predominantly concerned four or
five straight years now about jobs the
economy health care education
and then the fifth spot is usually some
combination of government spending or
energy or immigration but women have
made very clear for five straight years
what motivates them and then at their
very least in respecting America's women
from all these politicians ought to be
to meet that call unmarried women are
predominantly Democratic this is a
conundrum for the Republican Party
because there are more unmarried women
now five years ago by the age of twenty
five women had said I do now they say
well maybe I will sometimes later and
some at 35 say heck I won't and so the
Republican Party cannot wait for the
young to get old and the single to get
married to find new voters well on the
on the issue of jobs as we talk here
this morning a little bit after 8:30
Eastern the Labor Department has issued
the report for employment for the month
of August with the unemployment figure
falling from eight point three percent
to eight point one percent they say that
the economy has added ninety six
thousand jobs as more people and their
job searches so the unemployment rate
following of falling to eight point one
percent
how important was was this number for
the president this morning well you saw
some stories at the beginning of the
week bill that and whatever the jobs
report was going to say today it was
really poor timing to come out hours
essentially hours after the president's
primetime address at the convention and
why is that because the unemployment
rate is not five or six percent it
certainly isn't what Vice President
Biden promised it would be when they
signed the stimulus package in February
of 2009 a very long time ago and if you
look at 1984 versus 2012 many people
like to analogize you know that Reagan's
economy the unemployment rate was so
high in 1982 and 1983 that there are
analogies there but at this point in
2000 1984 the economy was much better
they were producing more jobs the
unemployment rate was lower and whether
people look at the unemployment rate
overall and say oh wow then I'm going to
vote for four more years I'm going to
kick Obama out of office the point is
that people need to feel it people don't
feel that we're recovering they don't
feel we're better off the wrong track
number is 65
percent the right direction is 32% we've
got a couple more minutes with Kelly and
Conway let's see if we can get a couple
of quick calls in here to Boca Raton
Florida on our Democrats line is
anamarie thanks for waiting and go ahead
yeah hi I just wanted to say that on the
Medicare cuts President Obama is the
cuts that he's making is for waste fraud
and abuse I don't know what the
Republicans are talking about I mean
just watching this channel is getting me
so upset well we don't want you to be
upset but I will tell you right there in
Florida in 1995 after Newt Gingrich
became Speaker of the House I went
around the state with him talking he was
talking to people all across the state
and the very first thing he wanted to do
17 years ago was cut the quote fraud
waste and abuse out of Medicare and yet
it was demagogue then politicized as
trying to cut Medicare so here we go
full circle that's not all that's being
cut in Medicare the there there are
independent analysts who have said so
there are government analysts who have
said so but since we're on the topic of
Florida I really want to say I thought
that one thing that Obama could have
done last night that he didn't do was
take advantage of the fact that
President Clinton who appeals to older
voters and working-class voters I felt
like he didn't sort of continue the
narrative because Bill Clinton could be
very very helpful to Barack Obama in a
state like Florida where this woman
resides which of course is a swing state
and again just like mm may hold the key
to this election well let's see we've
got another Florida caller on the line
Sarasota
Mike is on our Republican line thanks
for taking my call I live in a very
unique household I'm a conservative my
wife is a Democrat liberal teacher and
we have some very interesting
conversation we do a lot of research and
I took my wife
to see the movie 2016 Obama's America
after the movie walking out she says I
could never vote for that person
and and Mike she voted for him last
night
mm voted for Obama last time at the end
of the movie people were standing up
singing god Bless America that's that's
the second reference we've we've had to
2016
Kellyanne Conway have you seen that film
I have and the great Dinesh D'Souza
wrote the script and went around the
world filming it and really has done
everybody a public service frankly I
think it's not a mistake it's not an
accident why this I read last week is
really one of the most if not the most
lucrative and best received
documentaries on the conservative side
it will never be Michael Moore as
Fahrenheit whatever whatever but it's
really important and people should go
see it they should go see it with an
open mind because the whole point is
what will it be if he is elected for
four more years so tell your way thank
you thanks thank you Mike for calling in
last call here Ventura California
independent line Ralph go ahead yeah I'd
like to say two things first one what
it's angled web we weave the second
point I'd like to make is from Samuel
Clemens if you don't know that is that's
Mark Twain he said there's lies damned
lies and statistics okay now my point is
I'm 61 years old four years in the
Marines I have been in the oil fields I
have driven semis in all 48 lower states
I worked in the movie business and
you're just not telling the truth
do take a grain of truth you warp it you
wrap it and you package it but then
again that's your job now my point is
why can't a Republican actually just
tell the truth I don't even like a
Democrat to tell the truth but you don't
know what it is you've never been there
you've never had your hands blistered
you've never worked 12-hour day and only
made 50 bucks
Ralph Allah Kelly Ann Connolly respond
I'm sorry that you feel that way sarin
you don't know me I actually have
blistered my hands many times I worked
on a blueberry farm packing blueberries
for eight summers from the age of 12 to
19 I come from I'm very proudly come
from a very middle-class background a
single mom raised me along with her
family but so your
actually judging someone you don't know
and I know you're doing that from the
comfort of your you know from the
anonymity of the phone but I I'm not
really bill I'm not really into
insulting returning insults to guess I'm
just happy to be on c-span and to listen
to different diversity of opinion from
across the country but I do know what
it's like and frankly that's why I'm a
Republican because I believe that they
respect entrepreneurs and I believe this
is the greatest country ever built ever
ever created and frankly you prove that
by you giving us I'm a very impressive
quick rundown of the work experience
that you've had your ability to be in
this country and and to produce but I
know what it's like to work 12-hour days
I still do it many times I have four
little children I run a business and
everybody has their version the American
dream I'm just not going to return the
insults I wish you well sir
Kellyanne Conway heads the polling
company she's president and CEO you can
find more polling company dot-com thank
you for sharing part of your morning
with us here on Washington Joe thank you
all the best bill take care and in just
a bit we're gonna take a look at the new
jobless numbers that just came out
within the last couple of minutes our
guests will be Maryland G waxes the
senior economics correspondent senior
business editor at NPR will talk about
those jobless numbers and also about the
economy as an issue in the 2012 campaign
and then in our America by the numbers
series Paul Taylor from the Pew Research
Center joins us to talk about their
latest report on the middle class all of
that and more ahead you're on Washington
Journal
[Music]